[Music]
hey guys how's it going it's Nick and
I'm here with Denny from Bandai Namco
and we have the Dragonball Fighters
collector's edition and we're gonna find
out what's inside yeah we are really
excited to unveil the contents with you
guys obviously so let's get to it and
list all the top oh yes
alright so the first thing I see is
obviously the game itself so this is the
Xbox one version correct and obviously
there will be a PlayStation 4 version as
well inside the game box players will
also find their ssgss goku and vegeta
download code as well as two exclusive
equality avatars so then the next item
we have is the exclusive steelbook case
alright so on the front it looks like we
have boo cell and Frieza and then on the
back looks like we have Vegeta Goku and
Gohan a beautiful artwork
right next up we've got some artboards
and these actually so they're three are
people they aren't hearing artboards in
there we'll have you open them up very
careful yes it's the first one
here's the first one beerus super saiyan
alright so on the next one it looks like
we have Super Saiyan 3 Goku Gohan and
then Super Saiyan Vegeta we love how the
art just looks so alive yes awesome so
in this next one we have Android 17 and
18 and the hand drawing here what's
pretty incredible
[Music]
and then last but not least I know
everybody's been waiting to see this I'm
extremely excited Nick worthless bad boy
up he isn't trust me touch it all
wrapped up nice and securely packaged so
this Goku is a 7 inch statue it is I
believe a special manga artwork style
yes
so as you can see like while he is
painted the way they've done the
shadowing and and kind of like the
lighting effects on the statue itself he
really pops out of the background it
really comes to life
what's pretty incredible in this
lighting for sure definitely a very
unique statue in terms of the art style
I love the way it kind of has those
manga vibes in there which is also I
feel like a testament to the art side of
the game absolutely I mean we really
wanted to come across you know kind of
mirror that the art style of the game
because it is so unique and it's so
dynamic and definitely kind of portray
that in the statute
yeah so guys that was the Dragonball
Fighters collector's edition again
everything that comes in the box we have
the game itself we have the collectors
edition steelbook on this side we have
the three special edition artwork and
then obviously the awesome statue and
then don't forget you do get the ssgss
Vegeta and Goku playable characters as
the download inside the game inside the
game as well as to lobby avatars problem
cool so obviously this box is fully
packed with everything you talk full of
Dragon Ball goodness yes absolutely and
it's obviously this is the Xbox one
version but you can get the collector's
edition in PlayStation before its play
and how much is it and what days are
coming up we are looking at a MSRP of
one $39.99 and it's coming out on
January 26th which is the next Friday
and yeah we can't wait to get everybody
online and perfectly
I can't wait he can't wait thank you
guys for watching we'll see you next
time
[Music]